I'm Danica Patrick and I'm pretty
intense you're an advocate of
psychedelics and plant medicine for
again you know am I an advocate of open
relationship I don't know maybe if it's
right for you am I an advocate of plant
medicine I don't know maybe if it's
right for you it's it's a very personal
choice it's a lot of times these plant
medicines are trials by fire and are you
ready for are you ready for a trial bus
why did you why are you interested in it
like what made you interested in the
first place well because I'm not easily
I'm not easily you know taught I'm kind
of like I needed something big to show
me like I came into my first Vision
Quest which was a psilocybin Vision
Quest and the mountains of Mexico I came
into that and I was a staunch atheist I
was like sure and you die you die you're
done was the matter like this no soul
there's no anything like that like like
like sure I was so sure but I had enough
I had enough like curiosity and also
reverence for the Native American
culture that I was like okay Vision
Quest cool that sounds good I'm just
leaving high school you know sounds like
something that uh sounds like something
that a young warrior should do you know
so I decided that Vision Quest was for
me and I meet this beautiful you know
shaman out in out in New Mexico and just
like we're gonna have psilocybin tea and
I'm like oh God so I grabbed a rock from
them I rise this is your first time ever
with anything grabbed a rock from the
driveway and I was like as long as I
hold this rock I'll know that I'm still
here and bodied in this life you know
and I was like totally freaked out
and then what ended up happening was you
know at up to that point the most
beautiful experience of my life I felt
my body evaporate and I felt what could
only be described as my consciousness my
awareness or my soul exists independent
of my body and I was like oh [ __ ] I got
some things wrong mmm you know like I
didn't think there was this thing that
I'm experiencing in its purest form I
didn't even think this existed and that
moment of complete re-evaluation of
everything that I believed was what led
me down the path
and so it gave me faith in the process
gave me faith that these plants could be
used as teachers for someone as stubborn
and sure that he was right as I was and
completely shift my perspective and that
is you know to be fair I say this is for
everyone but the the clinical research
that's coming out is showing pretty
reliable data that psilocybin in the
right set and setting at the right dose
is reliably creating some of these top
life experiences for human beings so yes
it isn't for everyone but it's probably
for more of us than not not well when
you just look at the you know you look
at how many people die from alcohol or
you know synthetic drugs that are
prescribed to them versus natural plant
medicines
there's not even a comparison it's it's
like it's zero right I mean I think
there's a statistic on marijuana that
zero like nobody's died from ingesting
it like taking it in right correct it's
never been a death has it been a death
for many like can you OD on psilocybin
you would definitely take more than you
should
but I won't you know but it's not yeah
the the toxic effects right such a level
right that's not really right it's not
really what the issue if they can be
psychologically very traumatic and you
take too much but the question is why
why was it ever illegal in the first
place when these are natural products I
think people regulate against the things
that they're scared of themselves and
when the ego is in control right the ego
is firmly in control it's scared of the
reevaluation and scared of losing its
power seat running the human orgasm
right it it's almost like an entity that
itself wants to survive by the belief of
the organism that it exists in like the
ego wants to be real like I'm gonna be a
real boy yeah I'm gonna be a real boy
that's what the ego says and it's like
oh this thing so Simon might show the
embodied consciousness of the being that
I'm residing in that I'm not really that
real I'm just kind of a temporary
apparition that is operating within this
organism so well what's the ego gonna do
off the egos running the ship
maybe it can convince other people to
outlaw this thing and villainize it and
make it illegal I don't think it's this
grand conspiracy to keep people down and
to keep people stupid like people have
these big conspiracy days I think people
just regulate against the stuff that
they're afraid of okay and so people who
have strong egos were afraid of these
things that were ego dissolving and so
you know we outlawed those but the
consequences of that are that we don't
have the tools to really resolve the
traumas and really unwind some patterns
and I think that's the the revolution
that's coming with this next wave of
psychedelic medicine
[Music]